ANDREW HUBERMAN: Welcome to
the Huberman Lab podcast,
where we discuss science
and science-based tools
for everyday life.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
I'm Andrew Huberman,
and I'm a professor
of neurobiology
and ophthalmology
at Stanford School of Medicine.
Today is an Ask Me
Anything episode or AMA.
This is part of our
premium subscriber channel.
Our premium subscriber
channel was started in order
to provide support for
the standard Huberman Lab
podcast, which comes
out every Monday
and is available at zero cost
to everybody on all standard
feeds YouTube, Apple,
Spotify, and elsewhere.
We also started the
premium channel as a way
to generate support for
exciting research being
done at Stanford and elsewhere.
Research on human
beings that leads
to important
discoveries that assist
mental health, physical
health, and performance.
I'm also pleased to inform
you that for every dollar
the Huberman Lab Premium channel
generates for research studies,
the Tiny Foundation has
agreed to match that amount.
So now we are able to double
the total amount of funding
given to studies of mental
health, physical health,
and human performance.
If you'd like to subscribe
to the Huberman Lab podcast
premium channel, please go
to hubermanlab.com/premium.
It is $10 a month to subscribe,
or you can pay $100 all at once
to get an entire 12-month
subscription for a year.
We also have a lifetime
subscription model
that is a one-time payment.
And again, you can
find that option
at hubermanlab.com/premium.
For those of you that
are already subscribers
to the premium channel, please
go to hubermanlab.com/premium
and download the premium
subscription feed.
And for those of you that
are not Huberman Lab podcast
premium subscribers,
you can still
hear the first 20 minutes
of today's episode
and determine whether or not
becoming a premium subscriber
is for you.
So without further
ado, let's get
to answering your questions.
The first question
is about kratom.
And the question is, what are
the short and long-term effects
of taking kratom?
For those of you that
haven't heard of kratom,
kratom is a substance that
comes from a tree that
grows naturally in Indonesia.
The tree itself is called
mitragyna speciosa.
And it's been known for
hundreds of years or more.
We don't really know how long,
but at least for a couple
of hundred years,
that when people chew
the leaves of this tree, they
experience a mild stimulant
effect.
And there's also a
process of extraction
whereby you can take the leaves
and get high concentrations
of kratom that
nowadays is packaged
into various supplements.
Most often consumed
in capsule form,
although sometimes it's
sold in raw powder form.
Here's the key thing to
understand about kratom.
Indeed at low dosages, kratom
has a mild stimulant effect.
However, at higher
dosages, it has
what's called an
analgesic effect, that
is a painkilling effect,
and it acts as a sedative.
And kratom itself acts
as an opioid in the body.
This is what's making kratom
a very controversial topic
these days.
In particular,
because most people
have heard of the
so-called opioid crisis.
The opioid crisis
has been a term
coined to largely
center around issues
that have taken place
in the United States,
although these issues
definitely extend
beyond the borders
of the United States.
But the opioid
crisis is essentially
the overconsumption and
widespread addiction
to opioids.
Opioids include
things like morphine,
oxycodone, also
called OxyContin,
and there are other opioids
similar to those compounds,
all of which have the general
effect of being painkillers
and sedatives.
And in some people,
again some people,
eliciting a sense of
euphoria in particular
at low to moderate dosages.
However, people quickly develop
a tolerance to those drugs
and need to consume
more and more of them
in order to get the
effect that they initially
got from a lower dosage.
And they are not just
highly habit-forming.
They are highly addictive.
And we can distinguish
between habit
forming and addictive by simply
saying that addictive means
people will continue to take
something or do something
despite negative consequences.
There are other relevant
definitions of addiction
as well.
I define addiction more broadly
as the progressive narrowing
of the things that
give you pleasure.
And indeed, when people
get addicted to opioids,
it is a very bad picture.
It often hampers many,
many areas of their lives,
and seriously so.
So the opioid crisis refers
to the overprescription
of opioid drugs.
That's sort of what it
generally taken to mean.
But it also includes accessing
opioids such as morphine,
oxycodone, et cetera through
gray market sources through,
black market sources,
and on and on.
And of course, the
acquisition of the drugs
is just one piece it's
also the over consumption
of those drugs and, of course,
the addiction to those drugs,
which has proved to
be so pernicious.
So what does this have
to do with kratom?
Kratom is also an opioid.
And we'll talk
about how it differs
in its opioid properties from
the drugs I just talked about
because it is different from
morphine and hydrocodone,
but it also has some
similar properties as well.
But the deal with kratom
is that a good number
of people out there have
managed to wean themselves
off opioids such as
morphine and hydrocodone
through the use of kratom.
And that has been
used as justification
for keeping kratom on the
market and keeping it legal.
However, and this is a
very important however,
kratom itself has also proved
to be not only habit forming
but addictive, especially when
taken at dosages that exceed
that lower dose that
just generally creates
a bit of stimulant, a little
bit of euphoric effect.
When people start taking
higher dosages of kratom,
it is very clear that it
does become addictive,
and itself is very
hard to come off of,
so much so that people
experience so-called kratom
withdrawal.
Now the reason I
mentioned that kratom
has been used by a
good number of people
to wean themselves off
of the more potent forms
of prescription
opioids is that when
I solicited for questions
about kratom on social media,
it was a very binary response.
In fact, there was one
camp a very rabid camp
that said kratom is terrible.
I took this stuff.
I got addicted.
It was extremely
hard to come off of.
There were additional
comments in there,
such as I know
somebody who literally
had to go to rehab
because of kratom who
developed a bunch of other
addictions because of kratom.
Essentially many, many responses
of people who had only bad
experiences with kratom.
Meaning they liked
it enough at first
that they continued to take
it, and it became addictive
for them or somebody
that they know.
However, there was another
camp that was equally vocal,
which kept saying no if one
really adheres to the lower
dosages of kratom,
kratom itself can
be a useful tool for
getting off other opioids.
And there were even a few bona
fide medical professionals,
medical doctors that is,
and I happen to know them
and their reputations as quite
good, who chimed in and sort of
reconciled the two
camps by saying
indeed, if one can avoid taking
kratom at all, you should.
There is no reason to take
this thing thinking that it's
quote-unquote good for you.
You would be wise
to avoid taking it
because there is a high
probability if you take it
at a given dosage or at a dosage
that is going to get your brain
and body into a state
of euphoria, analgesia,
and the sort of
classic opioid effect
that it's going to become habit
forming or addicting for you.
That said, these same
medical professionals
acknowledged that a fair
number of people that they knew
managed to get off of the
more potent forms of opioids
such as morphine, oxycodone,
and so forth using kratom.
And they said, well if
it's a choice between being
addicted to morphine and
hydrocodone versus taking
kratom and addicted to those
substances and kratom somehow
allowed them to taper
off of those substances,
that they would look more
favorably upon kratom
if and only if they would
also commit to progressively
lowering their dose of kratom
and eventually coming off
of kratom.
So the general takeaway from
all of that is if you can avoid
taking kratom, meaning if
you haven't taken it already,
don't.
And that reminds me of a
very important point, which
a guest on the Huberman
lab podcast Dr. Robert
Malenka who's an
M.D. and Ph.D. He's
my colleague at Stanford
School of Medicine.
He's a world expert on the
mechanisms underlying addiction
and dopamine and
drug reinforcement,
among many other things.
What he said on the
podcast is absolutely true,
which is that it is impossible
to get addicted to a substance
that you've never consumed.
That might seem obvious but
think about that one again.
It is impossible to get
addicted to a substance
that you've never consumed.
So I think the safest
statement to make
is if you have not
tried kratom, you
would be wise to
avoid it because you
stand a chance to
become addicted to it.
If, however, you
are somebody that's
addicted to other
forms of opioids,
you absolutely should talk
to your physician about that
and how to get off
of those opioids.
But there is evidence that
some people have used kratom
to successfully wean themselves
off the more potent forms
of opioids that I
talked about, namely
morphine and hydrocodone,
as well as a few others.
Now if you're somebody
who already takes kratom,
you need to be very thoughtful
about the dosage that you take.
And you also need to be
thoughtful about the fact
that people differ dramatically
in their response to opioids.
This is oh so important,
and people do not
talk about this enough.
We hear, for instance, that, oh,
if people are taking anywhere
from one to five grams, maybe
one to six grams of kratom
per day, that's keeping
it in the dosage
range for which people don't
generally tend to get addicted,
you'll hear things like that.
And by the way, when I
say one to five or one
to six grams per
day, I'm not talking
about the individual compounds
that are present in kratom.
There are a couple of
different plant alkaloids
I'll talk about in a moment
that are present in kratom.
And these have different
effects on the opioid system.
So nowadays, some of the
companies that sell kratom.
And by the way, this is
sold over the counter
as a supplement.
It does not require
a prescription
to purchase, at least
at this point in time,
in the United States.
Some of these products will have
a higher concentration of one
or the other
alkaloids within them
such that you can't
really compare
one gram of one brand of kratom
to one gram of another brand
of kratom because they can
have wildly different levels
of these different alkaloids.
And these different alkaloids
have wildly different impact
on different aspects of
your brain and body biology.
In particular, how much
they tend to impact
the so-called endogenous
opioid system, OK.
So when we talk
about dosages, we
have to keep this in
the back of our mind.
And we have to keep in
the back of our mind
that there does seem to
be a subgroup of people.
We don't know how big this
subgroup of people is,
but we know it's not everyone,
but it's somewhere between 10
and 40% of people seem
to respond to opioids
in a particularly potent way.
They really like them.
And perhaps not surprisingly,
people outside of that category
don't tend to like opioids.
I can certainly say
that I am somebody
who, when I've been
prescribed things like Vicodin
or any other opioid
post-surgery for pain,
I hate taking those drugs.
I absolutely hate it.
I'd rather deal with the pain.
They make me nauseous.
They make me feel terrible.
That said, I know
people who love opioids.
It's like a natural fit for
their chemistry in the sense
that it tends to
evoke more euphoria.
They just immediately
like the feeling.
Some of you may remember the
episode of the Huberman Lab
podcast that I
did about alcohol.
And there, too, I discussed
the fact that about 8% to 10%
of people who consume alcohol
get an increased dopamine
response to alcohol that's
not observed in other people.
And that particular subgroup
of people is very, very at risk
for developing
alcohol use disorder,
sometimes called alcoholism,
because they can drink in a way
and they experience a high
from drinking in a way
that other people simply
do not experience.
Now like everybody else, if
they consume too much alcohol,
they get drunk.
So it's not about
the drunk effect,
it's about the dopamine
and other sorts
of chemicals that are released
in those people in response
to alcohol that other people
just don't seem to experience
at the same level of potency.
So again, with things like
kratom and the other opioids,
there's a category of people,
and it's a much larger category
of people, again 10% to 40%.
We don't know exactly how many
because the studies are not
really completed, and there
aren't enough of those studies
yet, unfortunately.
But when those people
take an opioid,
wow, oh, wow, do they like it.
And those people, in particular,
are very much at risk
for developing an
addiction to opioids.
And so those people, especially,
should never ever go near
kratom if they haven't.
Or if they are
already taking kratom,
these are the people
that are constantly
ratcheting up their dose.
These are the people that
tell you no, I'm not addicted,
but if you were to
say, hey, all right,
well then let's do an experiment
where you don't take kratom
for a week, those are going to
be the people that are suddenly
going to get anxious about
the mere idea of that.
I've also talked about
this in reference
to cannabis when I did an
episode about cannabis.
Again I'm not putting
a blanket statement out
there about cannabis
as being good or bad.
On that episode, I
talked about the fact
that cannabis does indeed
have various therapeutic uses.
But that there are a
good number of people
who rely on cannabis
for anxiety control
and other ways of modulating
their brain chemistry
and bodily chemistry such
that if you were to say,
hey, are you
addicted to cannabis?
They'd say no, I don't
have to smoke cannabis.
I don't have to take my edibles.
But if you were to push
them a little bit and say,
all right, well then,
let's do an experiment
where you don't
consume any cannabis
in any form for 10 days.
They don't like the idea
of that experiment at all.
So much so that were they
to run that experiment,
they would experience a lot
of the withdrawal symptoms
associated with addiction.
So I can't, in good
faith, say that kratom
is safe for everybody
because it is simply not.
Now is it safer than
the other opioids?
And if so, why?
Well, in order to
address that, let's
take a short glance at
the pharmacology of kratom
and how it works in terms of
its neurochemistry in the body.
Now I'm going to keep
this pretty brief
because, in the
future, I'm going
to do an extended episode
all about opioids,
and I will include kratom
in that conversation.
But just to back up a little bit
and discuss what opioids are.
Opioids are compounds
that can activate
the so-called endogenous
opioid system.
All of us have within
our brain and body
the capacity to release
our own opioids.
That's right.
You have opioids
within your body.
They are released from
neurons, and they bind
to so-called opioid receptors.
Perhaps some of you have heard
of the so-called runner's high.
The runner's high
is a euphoric state.
It's a fairly mild euphoric
state in most cases.
But it's a euphoric
state induced
by long-duration effort, a.k.a.
the runner's high.
The runner's high
is just a phrase
used to explain
that when we engage
in long-duration
repetitive action effort,
the body starts releasing these
endogenous opioids they bind
to receptors, and
they trigger things
like analgesia,
relief from pain.
They trigger mild euphoria.
They tend to change
our perception
of the outside
world, make things
look more beautiful, shiny.
They give things a
little bit of a sheen.
What I just described
is a mild version
of what people
experience when they
take something like morphine.
When people take
morphine, there's
a more of a sedative
effect, there's
more of a euphoric
effect, and there's
more of a dreamlike effect.
And again, it will
depend on dosage.
Kratom and morphine,
and hydrocodone all
have the property of acting
like the endogenous opioids
but at much higher potency.
When you bring them
into your system,
they cross the
blood-brain barrier.
So they go into
the brain, and they
bind to a number of
different opioid receptors.
There's the mu-opioid receptor.
By the way, these names all
follow Greek alphabet letters.
So the mu-opioid receptor,
the kappa opioid receptor,
there are a bunch
of different ones.
Kratom binds preferentially
to the mu-opioid receptor
and somewhat to the
kappa opioid receptor.
There's a big
misconception out there.
A lot of people,
especially people
who are proponents
of kratom, will
say no morphine and hydrocodone
bind the mu-opioid receptor,
whereas kratom binds the
kappa opioid receptor.
So it's a different compound.
Very, very different.
Not true.
Kratom, morphine, and
hydrocodone all bind
to the mu-opioid receptor.
And that's what's
largely responsible
for its opioid-like effects.
Especially when you get
the dosage up to a level
where you start getting the
mild sedation, the analgesia,
the pain relief.
And keep in mind a lot of
people are taking kratom
because they want pain relief.
And when that mu-opioid
receptor system is activated,
it indirectly activates a lot
of the reinforcement circuitry
in the brain that relates
to dopamine and serotonin.
This is another area that
we'll go into in more
depth in the future.
But there's been a
lot of controversy.
People saying, oh,
you know kratom
doesn't trigger the
dopamine system,
therefore, it's not addictive.
But that is simply not true.
It indirectly activates
the reinforcement circuitry
that includes both
dopamine and serotonin.
But its primary effect is to
hit this mu-opioid receptor
system that exists in a
bunch of places in the brain
but mainly in the
brainstem in a structure
called the periaqueductal
gray nucleus, which
then provides pain relief.
It triggers a number of
different shifts in cognition.
It's what creates that mild
euphoria, et cetera, et cetera.
Now how can we be so confident
that kratom is acting so
similarly to hydrocodone
and to morphine,
albeit with lower potency?
And the reason is
if you give people
a drug that blocks the
mu-opioid receptor prior to them
taking kratom, they
don't experience
any of the classic
effects of taking kratom.
No euphoria, no
analgesia, no sedation.
Even at the low dosages
no mild stimulant effect.
So we really have to look
at kratom as an opioid, OK.
That's just the honest truth.
And if you're somebody who
doesn't like this message
because you like kratom,
I'm not telling you
that you don't like kratom, I'm
telling you likely like kratom
because it's an opioid.
So again, if you go online
and you start asking questions
about kratom, again, you're
going to see these two camps.
You're going to see
the kratom is terrible,
it's addictive, it's
everything bad camp.
And then you're going to see the
other camp out there very vocal
as well, talking about how
kratom helped them avoid
other things that are worse.
And this is an argument
that, frankly, I
don't think we want
to lean on, right.
The idea that substance A is
not as bad as substance B.
And that making
substance A unavailable
is just going to send everyone
running for substance B. That's
a weak argument, frankly.
I heard this argument
around cannabis.
And by the way, I think pretty
balanced about cannabis.
If you listen to the
episode I did on cannabis,
I think you'll agree that
I believe that cannabis has
its therapeutic applications.
I also believe that young
people, especially young males
with a predisposition
to psychosis,
should not be taking
high-concentration THC
cannabis.
Because the data tell
us they are already
at risk of psychosis, and they
are at a much greater risk
of psychosis if they do.
So I think I'm pretty balanced
about the story on cannabis.
But I often hear the
argument oh cannabis
isn't as bad as alcohol and,
therefore, cannabis is good.
That's simply not rational.
What we should be
saying is whether or not
it's cannabis or
alcohol or kratom
or any substance for
that matter, what
are the potential benefits,
what are the potential risks?
And again, this is
far too much than we
can go into in this AMA.
And we will go into in a
future full-length episode
of the Huberman Lab podcast.
But the other thing
to really keep in mind
is the lack of regulation
over kratom supplements.
Now as many of you
know, I am a fan
of many, not all,
but many supplements
in certain conditions.
I always say behavior is
first, then nutrition.
Then if and only if it's
needed, rely on supplementation.
But supplementation
is a big category.
But when we're talking
about supplements
that are opioid
compounds, I start
to get nervous because
of the high abuse
potential and the high
addiction potential of opioids.
And kratom is included
in that category.
A couple of other key
notes about kratom.
While death directly from
kratom is fairly rare,
it has happened.
Now hydrocodone and morphine
suppress respiration.
Actually, suppress breathing
by way of a mechanism
that, if you're a listener
of the Huberman Lab podcast,
you know about.
Which is the so-called
physiological sigh.
Many of you have heard me talk
about the physiological sigh.
Is something that you do
voluntarily the double Inhale
through the nose and
then a long exhale
in order to rapidly reduce
your level of stress.
As far as we know,
that's the fastest way
to deliberately lower
your level of stress.
But the physiological sigh
was discovered in the 1930s
as a spontaneous
pattern of breathing
that occurs involuntarily
in sleep in order
to reinflate the lungs
and offload carbon dioxide
and bring oxygen
back into the system
on the subsequent breath.
When I interviewed
Dr. Jack Feldman, who
is a professor at University
of California Los Angeles
and really the pioneer of
the modern neuroscience
understanding of respiration,
he talked about some studies
in his laboratory that
were exploring why
people die when taking opioids.
This is a major issue associated
with the opioid crisis.
And what he mentioned
was that the opioids bind
to particular
receptors in the brain
stem locations that generate
physiological sighs.
So opioids, when taken as drugs,
suppress physiological sighing
and do so during sleep.
And lack of adequate
respiration,
meaning people stop
breathing during sleep,
is one of the primary
reasons why people
die when they take opioids.
Now kratom is not known
to suppress respiration
when taken at low
to moderate dosages.
But when combined with
any other opioids,
and certainly when
combined with alcohol,
it can suppress respiration.
And while the data on
this are fairly scant,
there is some evidence
that kratom-induced death
is caused by suppression
of the respiration system.
So again, death due
to taking kratom
at the dosages that
are recommended
on most commercial
packaging is fairly rare,
although it has happened.
It's unclear if it
happened because it
was taken in combination
with other compounds.
That seems likely.
But we can't forget
that a lot of people
are taking kratom at much
higher dosages and, in fact,
progressively higher
and higher dosages
from these
over-the-counter sources.
And with increased dosage,
there is, yes, an increased risk
of respiratory failure.
So again, all of this
points to the fact
that kratom is simply
not a benign substance.
So if we're going
to be very honest,
the addictive potential
of kratom is real.
It is exacerbated for some
people compared to others,
but it is real.
It's very similarities to other
more potent forms of opioids
are what make it attractive
for some people who
are trying to come off those
more potent form of opioids.
But the goal, of course,
is to completely come off
all opioids.
And kratom itself can
be a bit of a trap.
It can be a trap in
the sense that people
who have never
taken other opioids
can become addicted
to kratom itself.
That is absolutely
clear that can happen.
It has happened in a
great number of people.
It's also clear that kratom
can potentially be a trap.
Notice I said potentially.
Because if people are
trying to come off
other more potent
forms of opioids
and then they use
kratom to do that,
and then they're ratcheting
up their dosage of kratom such
that they're now matching the
endogenous response to kratom
in a way that doesn't really
distinguish from the effects
that they were getting from
morphine and hydrocodone,
well then they're just
using a different form
of morphine and hydrocodone.
And I'm sure that some
of you are out there
saying that is ridiculous.
You cannot compare the effects
of kratom to the effects
of hydrocodone.
But the potency is about
one-sixth of hydrocodone.
And there are
people out there who
are just increasing and
increasing both the dosage
and modifying the type
of kratom that they're
taking so that they're
getting the kratom that
has a particularly high
concentration of one
of the alkaloids that hits that
mu-opioid receptor hardest.
And in doing so,
sure, they're not
getting the pure
hydrocodone effect,
but they're getting
really close.
So my advice would be, if
you haven't touched kratom,
don't touch it at all, ever.
If you are taking
kratom, you need
to take note of what
we just discussed.
Thank you for joining
for the beginning
of this Ask Me Anything episode.
To hear the full episode and to
hear future episodes of these,
Ask Me Anything sessions plus,
to receive transcripts of them
and transcripts of the Huberman
lab podcast standard channel
and premium tools not
released anywhere else,
please go to
hubermanlab.com/premium.
Just to remind you why we
launched the Huberman lab
podcast premium channel,
it's really twofold.
First of all, it's
to raise support
for the standard Huberman
Lab podcast channel, which
of course, will still be
continued to be released
every Monday in full length.
We are not going to
change the format
or anything about the
standard Huberman Lab podcast.
And to fund research.
In particular, research
done on human beings.
So not animal models
but on human beings,
which I think we all
agree is a species
that we are most interested in.
And we are going to
specifically fund
research that is aimed
toward developing
further protocols for mental
health, physical health,
and performance.
And those protocols
will be distributed
through all channels, not
just the premium channel
but through all channels.
Huberman Lab podcast and
other media channels.
So the idea here is to give
you information to your burning
questions in depth.
And allow you the opportunity
to support the kind of research
that provides those kinds of
answers in the first place.
Now an especially exciting
feature of the premium channel
is that the Tiny
Foundation has generously
offered to do dollar-for-dollar
match on all funds raised
for research through
the premium channel.
So this is a terrific
way that they're
going to amplify whatever funds
come in through the premium
channel to further support
research for science
and science-related tools for
mental health, physical health,
and performance.
If you'd like to sign up for the
Huberman Lab Premium channel,
again, there's a cost
of $10 per month,
or you can pay $100 up
front for the entire year.
That will give you
access to all the AMAs.
You can ask questions and get
answers to your questions.
And you'll, of course, get
answers to all the questions
that other people ask as well.
There will also be some premium
content, such as transcripts
of the AMAs and various
transcripts and protocols
of Huberman Lab podcast
episodes not found elsewhere.
And, again, you'll be
supporting research
for mental health, physical
health, and performance.
You can sign up for the
premium channel by going
to hubermanlab.com/premium.
Again that's
hubermanlab.com/premium.
And as always, thank you for
your interest in science.
[MUSIC PLAYING]